we're on problem 81
81 and let's see
they give us this equation y is equal to
248
minus 398
x so which of the following values of x
gives the greatest value of y in the
equation above
which of the okay so we're going to to
get as large a possible y
let's see why is 248 minus this thing
minus this thing
right
so we want to do is since we're
subtracting this from 248 we want to
minimize this right as small as this can
be and even if we can make if we can
make what we're subtracting negative
that'd be awesome because then when you
subtract a negative then that'll get us
above 248 and actually if we look at all
of the choices they have one negative
number there you know you're you're you
might say oh if we put a zero here then
y is going to be 248 but what if we
actually put a negative number in for x
and that's to have his choice e negative
1. what happens when we put negative 1
there then y is equal to 248
minus
negative 1 times 398 so it's minus minus
negative 398
which is the same thing as plus 398. so
that's actually the maximum point
because we're subtracting a negative
right that's even better than
subtracting zero and it's way better
than subtracting a positive if we're
trying to maximize y
so the choice is e
82 machine a produces bolts at a uniform
rate of
120
volts
every
40 seconds
every 40 seconds
so that's the same as i see 120 volts
every 40 seconds is the same thing as 3
volts per second right yeah that's right
and machine b okay that's a
let me write that down that's a
machine b produces bolts at a uniform
rate of so this is b of 100 volts
every 20 seconds 20 seconds
well that's equal to 5
volts per second
if the two machines run simultaneously
how many seconds will it take for them
to produce a total of 200 volts so if
you're running simultaneously what's
your speed per second this one's gonna
do three per second this one's going to
do five per second so if you if they run
simultaneously you're going to be
producing eight per second three plus
five so eight volts per second is their
combined rate
and we want to know how many seconds
will it take to do 200 volts so we just
take 200 volts divided by eight seconds
right another way you know you with
distance your distance is equal to rate
times time
i guess you could view this as you know
production is equal to a rate times time
right normally rate is how fast you're
moving per second now it's how much
you're producing per second and so your
total production is going to be rate
your rate times time and then your time
is going to be the production divided by
the rate but i think
sometimes when you think too much in
terms of formulas you lose the intuition
but i just wanted to show you
uh that that there is a formula for it
if you need one but the easiest way to
think of it well i have to produce 200
volts i produce if i said i have i
produce 100 every second it's like oh
it'll take me 2 seconds so if i have to
produce 8 every second i take 200
divided by 8.
so 200 divided by eight and i can even
do the units 200 volts divided by eight
bolts per second
that's equal to 200
over eight
times bolts times if this is in the
denominator you just inverse it when you
go out seconds per bolt the bolts can't
slide so you know you got the units
right so to some degree that should give
you conviction that you got the formula
right and 200 divided by 8 is 25 right
so it's 25 seconds
is choice
b problem 83
problem 83
what is the decimal equivalent of
one-fifth
to the
fifth power
one-fifth to the fifth power so let's
think about this let's write one-fifth
as a decimal that's point two
so it's point two
to the fifth power
so let's just i don't know let's just
multiply it out point two times point
two
is equal to what two times two and we
have two digits behind the decimal so
it's .04
and then you multiply that times point
two
times
0.2
2 times 4 is 8 and now we have three
numbers behind the decimal point that's
going to be equal to 0.08
sorry 008
right
1 2 3 3 numbers behind the decimal so
this is two to the third
and then
.008 times 0.2 let me write this is to
the third power
that's equal to 2 times 8 is 16 and then
how many numbers do we have behind the
decimal point one two three four so
we're going to have
point one two three four so that's to
the fourth power we have one left so
.0016 times 0.2 is equal to 2 times 16
is 32 and now we have one two three four
five numbers behind the decimal point so
one two three four five
that's the answer and that is
choice a
choice a another way actually the
easiest way to think about it is without
having to even do this you could have
said oh what's 2 to the 5th power
2 to the fifth power is
right and actually that alone because
there's only one choice that even has a
32 behind the decimal point and you can
say oh and every time i take to a power
i'm adding one digit behind the decimal
point so it's going to be 32 but it's
going to have five numbers behind the
decimal point so point one three
i did it the slow way
next question 84
84
90
minus
8
times 20
i'll write the way they did 20 divided
by 4
all of that over
1 half this is just a fast
simplification problem that becomes 90
minus what's 20 divided by 4. 20 by 4 is
5 5 times 8 is 40
all that over one-half that becomes 50
over one-half which is the same thing as
50
times 2 over 1 which is equal to 100
that's choice c that's just one you just
have to do quickly and not make a
careless mistake
i hope i
i did it quickly i don't know if i did a
careless mistake let's see 85 a dealer
originally brought a hundred identical
battery batteries at a total cost of q
dollars
so q is equal to 100
batteries
if each battery was sold
at 50 percent above the original cost
so let's b is the cost that each battery
was sold at so b
is going to be 50 above the original
cost so it's going to be 1.5 times the
original cost right this is 50 above the
original cost per battery then in terms
of q for how many dollars for how many
dollars
was each battery
sold
oh they just threw us you know
let's see a dealer a dealer
a dealer originally bought 100 identical
batteries at a total cost of q dollars
if each battery was sold oh i'm sorry
so this is the cost
right
so
q
is equal to 100 times what the dealer
paid for it
right a dealer originally bought 100
identical batteries at a total cost of q
dollars
right
if each battery was sold at 50
above the original cost per back battery
so the selling price this is the
original cost is equal to 1.5
times the cost
times the cost in terms of q for how
many dollars was each battery sold so
let's write q in terms of the cost so
cost is equal to q divided by 100 just
divided both sides of that equation by
100
and then we could just substitute c or
the cost here for here the selling price
is 150 of this
so selling price is equal to 1.5 times c
which is q over 100
q over 100
and let's see how they
they did so selling price is equal to
1.5
q over 100 i don't expect to see
that as a choice but if we multiply
if we multiply
the top and the bottom by 2 that equals
3
q
over 200
3q over 200 that's choice a
make sure you get your variables right
in that one
problem 86
an increasing sequence in an increasing
sequence of 10 consecutive integers the
sum of the first five integers is 560
what is the sum of the last five
integers in the sequence okay 10
consecutive integers
so x plus one plus x
plus let me write it this way x plus one
plus x
plus two well actually the first one
let's call it x
x plus three
x plus four right these are the first
this right here is going to be the first
five consecutive integers if we started
x right
when you take the sum of those
that well the sum of those this is one
two three four five x
five x and see one plus two is three
three plus three is six six plus four is
ten
five x plus ten is going to be equal to
they tell us it's equal to five hundred
sixty
fair enough or we could say five 5x is
equal to 550.
i think we can use that information
now what is the next five integer is
going to be it's going to be
x plus 5
x plus 6
x plus 7
x plus 8 and x plus 9 right these are 5
and what do those add up to be that's 5x
plus 5 plus 6 is 11 plus 7 is 18 plus 8
is 26
plus 9
26 plus 9 is 35 so that's 5x plus 35 and
they want to know
they want to know what this is equal to
right that's the next 5. well we know
that 5x is that's equal to 550 from this
setup
so it's going to be equal to 550
plus 35
which is equal to 35 plus 550 is just 5
85
585 that's choice a and the trick here
to being able to do it fast is just to
recognize that you didn't have to solve
all the way for x that you could reuse
this 5x when you took the sum of the
next five
and i'm all out of time see in the next
video